so we're in this topic of polynomials
and for a lot of us this is kind of like
oh yeah a lot of stuff that we have
known over the past few years is
actually coming together like when we
have the first look at graphing you're
like ah this connects this connects to
calculus it connects a algebra that
we're doing before this connects to all
the functions that we did right at the
start of the year so we're kind of
continuing a theme we're going to take
some of the knowledge that we've had
before and use it to prove verify and
then sort of extend this interesting
relationship and we'll get a little bit
later on to why this relationship is
interesting for now we're going to use
this as our example to consider which
will help us show what this relationship
is and then what we're going to do as
mathematicians often do is we'll go from
a specific example and we'll see if we
can do what we call generalizing good
morning come on in there's plenty of
seats right there when you have a look
at it I haven't told you to do anything
with it but does anyone have any
instincts for what we could do with it
today we help us work with it keep you
in mind you don't know what I'm us I'm
asking you to do with it yet but what
could we perhaps do yeah
we can factorize you see absolutely
before we start thinking about like how
we're going to write this with some
brackets and all that kind of thing
is there anything simple we can do or
sorry that number on the end should be
an 8 that's an 8 is there anything
simple we can do to make that
factorization a bit simpler essent yeah
I
each one of these numbers that's why
notice my number was wrong H now these
in one of these numbers is a multiple of
three so I can just factor that out
let's do that so I'm gonna write out the
front a three and what does that leave
me with on the inside of the brackets
okay I got an x-squared someone take
over what's next somebody just walked in
you can see this
tell me what's what's next come on you
guys can all see this it's my next term
I am gonna have an X but how many of
them after I take out the three five of
them right very good
and then last term along the constant
one plus six right okay happy times so
we've taken out a common factor and now
when you have a look at this thing you
can see why I chose these numbers these
are really easy to deal with
right we're searching for a pair of
numbers add to that multiply that and
those two numbers of course are ah
interesting so I am going to write a
eventually minus 2 and minus 3 but those
are not the factorization you're
actually going to the next step
serene when I'm just doing the
factorization I'm not minus 2 minus 3
the numbers I want are plus 2 plus 3
right I'm going to write my
factorization like so and the minus 2
minus 3 where they come in are they are
as the heading suggest to you they are
what we call the zeros of this
polynomial this is our polynomial P of X
why do you think zeros remember we've
talked about this language before why do
we call them zeroes minus 2 and minus 3
what happens with them yeah there they
are the x-intercepts we've talked about
x-intercepts we've talked about roots
and we've talked about zeroes I want you
to look again at the web zeroes it's a
bit weird to say negative 2 is a zero of
this but why would that actually be a
sensible name restin they make the whole
thing zero
please mark that right let's actually
write that down I'm gonna put it in
different color just to highlight it
right I'm going to say x equals negative
2 and x equals negative 3 zeros of this
polynomial right they are zeroes of P of
X because if we took negative 2 and
negative 3 and substituted them in P of
negative 2 P of negative 3 that you get
zero out of this and that's why we call
them that ok now these two numbers here
negative 2 and negative 3 I wonder if
you can see there is a relationship
between these two that you can get
straight out of here without doing any
of this factorization let me see if I
can tease it out for you a little more
let's give these two x equals negative 2
and x equals negative 3 let's give them
names well it's cold this guy over here
alpha and we'll call this guy over here
beta these are my two zeros when asked
to do two things with them number one
we're gonna add them up see what we get
see if there's anything interesting then
we're going to multiply them see if we
get anything interesting okay
so to add them the way I would write
that the sum of these two roots I'll
write that is alpha plus beta right
there we go when you take our particular
values alpha be negative 2 negative 3
yeah and together we get of course
negative 5 okay let's just hit pause on
that guy and then the other thing I
wanted to do was multiply them together
that's not a sum what happens the what's
the answer called when you multiply two
things together
it's a products right it's a product
that's what happens when you multiply
two things together so I would write
that as not alpha plus beta but alpha
times beta I'm just gonna leave out the
times what do you get what's the utter
it's six right okay now I wonder if you
notice there is a clear relationship
between these two numbers that you've
gotten out here and our original the
first line of this our polynomial right
and there's relationships all the way
through there's a relationship from
these guys to here and also these guys
to here let's start with this line it's
a bit easier to see where do you see six
like where do you see it it's just the
constant term it's just right there
isn't it right there six where's
negative five that's a little trickier
to see because it's negative maybe I
should ask where this is where's this
guy where's the five we have language
for this right it's the coefficient of x
thank you right it's that guy right
there so where do we see this it's the
negative of the coefficient of x right
hmm but to get to this line what we had
to do first was we had to factorize out
do usually that we had to take out this
factor it was went all the way through
okay so in fact how can we get six and
negative five just out of this very
first line well this is an appropriate
call we're going to take that thing
right down the end when we look at this
quadratic we would normally write it as
this ax squared plus BX plus C that's
the general form you can describe any
quadratic you like in this way right
we took this last number and then to get
to 6 to factorize out I
well I divided didn't I I divided by
whatever this coefficient at the front
was right so I took C and then I divided
by this coefficient front
you happy with that do you see that
that's where I could get six without
having to factorize I could go straight
to this value if I were so interested in
it said all right when you have a look
at this one I didn't look at that last
term I looked at the middle one the
coefficient of x so that's not see
that's that's B that's what we call it
right the coefficient of x right there
it's B I factorize doubt so again just
like here I divided through by a but
then there was one last thing you like
oh you don't get negative five here you
just get positive five so it's not quite
beyond a it's the opposite that's the
negative version so I'm just gonna write
a minus sign at the front does that make
sense look back at the first line just
kind of mentally blank out all of this
if I asked you to find out what the sum
of the roots was we wouldn't have to go
through all of this process we could get
it straight from this line I could say
minus B minus 15 divide that by three
and you'd get the negative five
okay so if I have a look at these two
here these are kind of like a shortcut
to get straight to the sum of the two
roots and the product of the two roots
without having to go through this
factorization process okay now